THINGS OFF EVERY SINGLE DAY
HERE ON PEACOCK NBC SPORTS ON
TALK LIVE PROGRAM AND PFT P.M.
WRAPS UP THE DAY EVERY
MIKE FLORIO. HOW ARE YOU MIKE
FLORIO RICH DOING GREAT BUDDY.
HOW ARE YOU? I AM DOING WELL.
HAPPY MARCH CIRHAPPY MARCH.
THIS IS WHERE IT'S ALL GOING
TO GO DOWN FROM FREE AGENCY
FRANCHISE
TAX.
NEW TELEVISION CONTRACTS IS A
BUSY MARCH WHEN YOU SAY WELL
NO. NO, IT WAS A BEAUTY
FEBRUARY AND THERE REALLY
WASN'T MUCH THAT WAS GOING ON.
I THINK THE QUARTERBACKS ALL
GOT TOGETHER AND THEY PARSED
OUT THE DAYS THAT THEY WOULD
DOMINATE THE NEWS CYCLE. I
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE ONCE
WE GOT THROUGH THE SUPER BOWL,
IT'S LIKE OKAY, THERE'S NO
SCOUTING COMBINE. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO KNOW THE SALARY CAP
TEAMS AREN'T GOING TO DO
DEALS WITH THEIR CURRENT
PLAYERS UNTIL WE KNOW THE CAP
GUYS ARE GOING TO GET CUT
EVENTUALLY BUT NOT MAYBE ALL
THAT MANY IN FEBRUARY. WHAT
ARE WE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THE WILSONS DESHAUN WATSON,
AND WHOEVER ELSE HAPPENED TO
POP UP. I MEAN IT WAS GREAT
AND I REALLY RESPECT THE FACT
THAT THEY TRIED TO SPREAD IT
OUT BECAUSE THAT REALLY
HELPED US GET THROUGH. WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN A SLOW MONTH?
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT DESHAUN
WATSON HERE. MIKE IS THE
TEXANS PLAN TO JUST WAIT IT
OUT AND HOPE HE COMES AROUND
COME AROUND BEFORE THEY ARE L
PUT IN A POSITION TO FIND HIM
FOR NOT BEING IN PLACES WHERE
HE'S CONTRACTUALLY OBLIGATED
TO BE
IS THAT IS THAT BASICALLY
THEIR PLAN? WELL, WHATEVER
THEIR ACTUAL PLAN IS. THEY'RE
DOING A GOOD JOB OF CREATING
THE IMPRESSION THAT THEIR
PLAN IS. WE'RE NOT DOING
ANYTHING. WE HOPE THAT HE
WILL CHANGE HIS MIND. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO TRADE THIS GUY
EVEN THOUGH THE FACT THAT
IT'S GOTTEN TO THIS POINT IS
ALREADY AN INDICTMENT ENOUGH
OF THE TEXANS. YOU DON'T LET
IT GET TO THIS POINT WITH A
FRANCHISE QUARTERBACK WITH
THE SHORT LIST ONE OF THE TOP
PLAYERS IN THE NFL. IT'S
GOTTEN TO THIS POINT AND I'VE
INDICATING THAT WATSON'S
RESOLVE IS A RUSE OR
CONTRIVED OR SOMETHING THAT
HE'D ABANDON IF PUSH COMES TO
SHOVE ALL SIGNS ARE HE'S MADE
UP HIS MIND. HE'S CROSSED THE
RUBICON AND THAT'S THAT HE'S
NOT GOING TO PLAY FOR THE
TEXANS EVER AGAIN, AND I
DON'T KNOW WHERE THE TEXANS
NEED TO TO SEE THAT FOR
THEMSELVES, BUT YOU KNOW THE
LONGER YOU WAIT THE MORE YOU
JEOPARDIZE YOUR ABILITY TO
GET MAXIMUM VALUE AND THEY
CAN PROBABLY PUSH IT.
UP TO THE DRAFT TO GET
MAXIMUM VALUE, BUT ONCE THE
DRAFT PICKS ARE MADE FOR THIS
YEAR. I THINK IT BECOMES
HARDER AND HARDER IF THEY
HAVE THE REALIZATION THAT THE
GUY TRULY WANTS OUT. HE'S NOT
GOING TO SHOW UP. WHAT ARE
THEY GOING TO DO? I MEAN IF
YOU DON'T TRADE HIM, HE
DOESN'T SHOW UP. WHO'S YOUR
QUARTERBACK FOR 20 21, AND
DONE NOTHING TO GET VALUE FOR
THIS GUY? SO HE SITS OUT A
YEAR AND THEN YOU SAY A YEAR
FROM NOW. JEEZ. WELL, I GUESS
HE WAS SERIOUS. IT JUST IT
MAKES NO SENSE TO ME IF
THAT'S THEIR PLAN. WELL,
HERE'S HERE'S THE DEAL FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE MIKE AND
LET'S CHOP THIS UP A LITTLE
BIT HERE BECAUSE
DESHAUN WATSON ASKED FOR A
TRADE TO MAN, BUT HE DOESN'T
DO IT PUBLICLY. WE FIND OUT
SUBSEQUENTLY WHEN PUSH COMES
TO SHOVE ON THIS SUBJECT
MATTER IN JANUARY AND THEN HE
MEETS WITH DAVID KELLY
ACCORDING TO A REPORT AND WE
FIND OUT ABOUT THAT
THAT OUT.
THE DAY OF HE'S NOT HE'S NOT
HE'S NOT PUTTING ANY PRESSURE
HE'S KIND OF SLOW PLAYING IT
AS WE'VE SEEN BEFORE LIKE FFS
THIS WHERE I'M NOT COMING IN.
I WANT TO TRADE ARE BASED ON
FINANCES WANTING TO
RENEGOTIATE A CONTRACT
EARLIER THAN THEN CONVENTION
ALLOW IS IN THE NFL OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, BUT HE'S
ALREADY SIGNED HIS MONSTER
ON HIRING SOMEBODY THAT WILL
INFLUENCE HIS WINS AND LOSSES
THAT HORSE IS ALREADY LEFT
THE BARN AS WELL THAT LEAVES
THE SUBJECT MATTER OF I DON'T
WANT TO PLAY FOR THAT GUY WHO
SIGNS MY CHECKS WHOSE
CONTRACT I DID ACCEPT A YEAR
AGO. THERE'S NO WAY OUT OF IT.
THAT'S THAT THAT'S MY
SPIDEY-SENSE TELLING ME THIS
IS OVER AND YOU MIGHT AS WELL
STRIKE IT WHILE THE IRON'S
HOT BEFORE FREE AGENCY WHEN
OTHER TEAMS MIGHT BE OUT OF
THE RUNNING BECAUSE THEY GO
AHEAD AND GET QUARTERBACK A B
AND C WHO CLEARLY ISN'T
WATSON CALIBER YOUR THOUGHTS.
SAME PAGE A HUNDRED PERCENT
AND ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
WATSON HASN'T SAID ANYTHING
IS HE DOESN'T THINK HE NEEDS
TO SAY ANYTHING. THERE WAS
AN ITEM IN THE ATHLETIC ABOUT
10 DAYS AGO THAT EXPLAINED HE
HAS A VERY STOIC DEMEANOR AND
HE PRIDES HIMSELF ON THAT AND
IT WAS AN INSPIRATION THAT HE
GOT FROM HIS MOTHER WHEN SHE
WAS FIGHTING CANCER, AND HE I
BELIEVE DOESN'T THINK HE
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO PUT THAT
DIRECT PRESSURE ON THE TEAM
AND MAYBE THAT'S A CARD. HE'S
HOLDING FOR LATER.
IF WE GET INTO THE MIDDLE OF
MARCH AND IF THEY CONTINUE TO
REFUSE AND MAYBE HE'S GOT TO
SAY SOMETHING REVEALS
SOMETHING DISCLOSE SOMETHING
SIT DOWN FOR AN INTERVIEW AND
BE MORE CANDID IN WHY HE
WANTS OUT. I THINK HE WANTS
TO GIVE IT EVERY FAIR
OPPORTUNITY TO HAPPEN WITHOUT
HIM HAVING TO BE DIRECT AND
OPEN AND CANDID ABOUT WHAT IT
IS. THAT'S BOTHERING HIM. AND
YOU KNOW, IF I'M THE TEXANS I
GETTING THIS DEAL DONE BEFORE
HE PULLS THE PIN ON A GRENADE
AND TELLS THE WHOLE WORLD ALL
THE THINGS HE SEES WRONG WITH
THAT ORGANIZATION RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT GOING TO
HELP THE ORGANIZATION GOING
FORWARD MIKE FLORIO PRO
FOOTBALL TALK HERE ON THE
RICH EISEN SHOW. SO WE'LL
JUST WAIT TO SEE WHEN BOTH
THE SIDES DECIDE. WHAT A
PRESSURE POINT IS IN ORDER TO
MAKE A MOVE AND SEE HOW IT
GOES BEFORE THE DRAFT YOU
MENTIONED IN ATHLETICS STORY
ABOUT WATSON THE ONE ABOUT
RUSSELL WILSON CERTAINLY
CAUGHT MY EYE ON
I KNOW WHAT CAUGHT YOURS AS
WELL. DO YOU THINK THIS COULD
WIND UP WITH WATER WITH
RUSSELL WILSON SOMEWHERE ELSE
MIKE? I THOUGHT THAT IT WOULD
HAPPEN NEXT YEAR UNTIL I READ
THAT ARTICLE AND I THINK IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THAT ARTICLE
WHICH CONTAINS SURELY ITEMS
FROM THE SEAHAWKS WHO HAVE
SAID NOTHING PUBLICLY.
THEY'VE BEEN THE MIRROR IMAGE
OF THE TEXAN SITUATION. WE'RE
IN HOUSTON. IT'S TEXANS
TALKING QUARTERBACK ISN'T IN
SEATTLE. IT'S QUARTERBACK
TALKING TEAM ISN'T BUT
SOMEBODY FROM THE
TEAM SHARED SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION WITH THE ATHLETIC
AND RICH WHEN I GOT TO THE
END OF THAT STORY AND AND I I
BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY THAT
ANYONE WHO READS EVERY WORD
OF ONE OF THESE HASHTAG LONG
READ STORIES SHOULD GET A
T-SHIRT WHEN I GOT TO THE END
OF IT I SAID, YOU KNOW, IF
THE SEAHAWKS DON'T VIEW
RUSSELL WILSON THE WAY THAT
RUSSELL WILSON VIEWS RUSSELL
WILSON, WHY NOT TRADE HIM TO
A TEAM THAT DOES BECAUSE THAT
TEAM WILL OFFER SOMETHING
THAT MAKES THE SEAHAWKS A
IDIOTS THINK HE'S PATRICK
MAHOMES. SO IT'S
SEEMS LIKE IT'S INEVITABLE
AND IF IT IS INEVITABLE, YOU
CAN EITHER PEEL THE BAND-AID
OFF SLOWLY OR JUST RIP IT OFF
NOW AND I THINK IF THEY
BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
AT SOME POINT. WHY NOT DO IT
NOW? WHY NOT MAXIMIZE YOUR
PACKAGE AND HOPE THAT THESE
FOUR TEAMS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED BY HIS AGENT LAST
WEEK UNPRECEDENTED. I FELL
OUT OF THE CHAIR WHEN THE
AGENT LISTS THE FOUR TEAMS
THAT RUSSELL WILSON WOULD
ACCEPT A TRADE TO PLAY THEM
AGAINST EACH OTHER GET YOUR
BEST OFFER AND MOVE ON. I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF WISDOM
IN DOING THAT IF YOU THINK
YOU'RE ON A COLLISION COURSE
FOR A DIVORCE WITH RUSSELL
YEAH, AND IT'S INTERESTING
YOU SAY THAT IF YOU'RE NOT
VIEWING RUSSELL WILSON THE
WAY THAT HE WANTS TO BE
VIEWED OR YOU'D THINK MOST
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS WOULD
THEN WHY WOULD YOU KEEP THEM?
WHY HAVE THAT WHAT Y WAS ARE
SET UP AT ALL WHERE WHERE
RUSSELL IS B IS TOLD THANKS,
BUT NO, THANKS AND HE STORMS
OUT OF THE ROOM AGAIN. YOU
HOW STORIES GET TOLD
SOMETIMES WHETHER IT'S
EMBELLISHED OR NOT OR WHO'S
THE WHAT'S THE REASON WHY
SOMEBODY IS TELLING THIS
STORY OR NOT WHERE IT COMES
FROM IS OF IMPORTANCE, BUT
THAT ONE
DID SURPRISE ME? IT'S LIKE
WHY WHY WOULDN'T RUSSELL
WILSON BE ALLOWED TO DO WHAT
HE REALLY WANTS. I UNDERSTAND
THAT PLAYERS STILL NEED TO BE
COACHED AND COACHES STILL
NEED TO HAVE THEIR INFLUENCE
ON THE WAY. THINGS ARE RUN.
BUT HOW IN THE WORLD IS THAT
NOT? HOW IS THAT HAPPEN WHERE
RUSSELL IS TOLD? YA THE LAST
SEVEN TURNOVERS ARE MOSTLY
YOUR FAULT. GET OUT OF THE
ROOM. WELL, THAT'S A PRESSURE
POINT. I THINK THE MOST
OBVIOUS ONE ON THE
TRANSFORMATION. WE'RE SEEING
WITH QUARTERBACKS.
MORE POWER MORE INFLUENCE
MORE CONTROL AND I THINK THE
TOM BRADY TRACK THE TAMPA BAY
AND WHAT THEY WERE ABLE TO DO
IN HIS FIRST YEAR THERE HAS
THROWN A WRENCH INTO A LOT OF
THESE QUARTERBACK
RELATIONSHIPS AND WHETHER
SOMEONE DECIDES TO TAKE IT
PUBLIC LIKE RUSSELL WILSON OR
WHETHER SOMEONE IS STEWING
PRIVATELY WITH A GLASS OF
SCOTCH LIKE AARON RODGERS AND
I SUSPECT THAT HE IS THEY SEE
WHAT BRADY DID HE PICKED HIS
TEAM CALLED HIS SHOT. THEY'VE
DEFERRED TO HIM EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY AND THEY BUILD THE
TEAM AROUND HIM.
AND RUSSELL WILSON WANTS A
TEAM WHERE THE OFFENSE WILL
RUN THROUGH HIM LIKE IT DOES
WITH PATRICK MAHOMES. I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
HE'S INTRIGUED BY THE BEARS
BECAUSE IT'S AN ANDY REID
ASSISTANT WHO RUNS THAT SAME
OFFENSE AND FINE. LET ME DO
WHAT PATRICK MAHOMES DOES IN
THE SAME OFFENSE BECAUSE
OTHERWISE YOU LOOK AT THE
BEARS AND SAY RUSSELL WHY THE
HELL DO YOU WANT TO PLAY FOR
THE BEARS? THAT'S THE REASON
WHY SO I I THINK THAT
THE BRADY DYNAMIC IS CAUSING
GUYS WHO USED TO BE
PETRIFIED ABOUT BECOMING
DOWNTOWN'S RUSSELL WILSON
WILLING TO PUT IT OUT THERE
WILLING TO GO AGAINST THE GO
HAWKS GRAIN AND LET IT BE
KNOWN THAT HE WANTS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT AND YOU KNOW, WHAT
MOST FANS HAVE REACTED BY
SAYING, YOU KNOW, WHAT THE
GUYS GOT A POINT MIKE FLORIO
HERE ON THE RICH EYES AND
SHOW WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
DREW BREES YOUR WE ARE IT'S
MARCH 1ST, AND HE'S NOT
RETIRED AND OVER THE WEEKEND
HIS HIS HYPER-ENERGETIC
TRAINER TODD DURKIN
INSTAGRAMS OUT VIDEOS OF
HIM DAMN NEAR SHOVING A SLED
INTO TRAFFIC. I GOT A LITTLE
SCARED FOR A SECOND. BUT
BREATHE THANKFULLY STOPPED
THE SLED FILLED WITH WEIGHTS
AND DID TURN AROUND AND WENT
UP THE HILL WITH IT AND AND
DURKINS MESSAGE DID
DEFINITELY MADE IT SEEM LIKE
THIS ISN'T A WRAP FOR BREEZE
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
DURATION OF THAT VIDEO
SOUNDED JUST A LITTLE
CONTRIVED. IF NOT REHEARSE,
DIDN'T IT? I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON.
I KNOW IS THIS SEAN PAYTON
MADE THE ROUNDS THE WAKE OF
THE SUPER BOWL. HE WAS ON PFT
LIVE ON WEDNESDAY OF THAT
WEEK FOUR WEEKS AGO TWO DAYS
FROM NOW. HE SAID WE EXPECT
AN ANNOUNCEMENT WITHIN A WEEK
WEEK AND A HALF AND
EVERYTHING HAS POINTED TO
DREW BREES RETIRING AND RICH.
HE REDOES HIS CONTRACT AND
SLASHES HIS SALARY FROM 25
MILLION TO THE MINIMUM OF ONE
.075 WITH NO QUID PRO QUO. NO
SIGNING BONUS NO MONEY BEING
MOVED AROUND HE CUT TWENTY
FOUR POINT NINE TWO FIVE
IN THE STROKE OF A PEN.
AS PART OF AN EFFORT TO
MINIMIZE THE CAP HIT WHILE
THEY CARRY HIM ON THE ROSTER
UNTIL JUNE 2ND PROCESSES
RETIREMENT THEN MINIMAL CABOT
THAT I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE
ABSOLUTE SMOKING GUN THAT
HE'S RETIRING AND HE STILL
HASN'T RETIRED AND HE'S OUT
THERE PUSHING THIS SLED
AROUND AND AND AND I THINK
THAT SOME PEOPLE AROUND THE
SAINTS ARE STARTING TO WONDER
WHAT THE HELL IS GOING ON
HERE AND AND MICKEY LOOMIS
THE GM HAS BEEN ON RECORD
SAYING HE CAN PLAY AS LONG
AS HE WANTS WHICH I DON'T
HAPPENING TODAY, RIGHT? IT'S
JUST KIND OF WITH BY IT'S A
LITTLE MORE CONSPICUOUS THAT
DREW BREES HASN'T DONE. WHAT
WHAT EVERYONE THOUGHT HE WAS
GOING TO DO. AND AND IF YOU
KNOW LOOK FOR THE PAST YEAR
THE TOOTHPASTE HAS BEEN OUT
OF THE TUBE THAT IT'S HIS
LAST YEAR AND DREW'S NEVER
SAID ANYTHING TO THE CONTRARY.
SO WE JUST WATCH AND WE WAIT
AND YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW.
WELL, I'D BE STUNNED IF HE
DECIDES TO GIVE IT ANOTHER GO.
I THINK THIS IS ANOTHER
IMPACT OF TOM BRADY THIS TEAM
THAT THE SAINTS SWEPT IN THE
REGULAR SEASON AND BE
38 2 3 ON THE SAME FIELD
WHERE THE BUCCANEERS HOISTED
THE LOMBARDI TROPHY THEY
CATCH THE SAINTS FLAT-FOOTED.
THEY BEAT THE SAINTS THEY RUN
THE TABLE. THEY WIN THE SUPER
BOWL. HOW CAN DREW BREES NOT
THINK AT SOME LEVEL I CAN GO
ONE MORE YEAR AND WE CAN TRY
TO GET THE LOMBARDI AND IF I
DON'T DO IT, I'M GOING TO BE
TORMENTED BY THE FACT THAT I
DIDN'T GIVE IT A TRY FOR THE
REST OF MY LIFE. YEAH. I MEAN
LOOK AT TOM TOMS OUT THEIR
AGE 43 AND YOU KNOW THROWING
A PAST HIS SON AS HIS
BEAUTIFUL, YOU KNOW DREW'S
BEAUTIFUL.
BRITNEY LOOKS ON AND WE'RE
ALL THINKING. WELL, THAT'S IT
FOR DREW BECAUSE BRADY JUST
BEAT HIM IN THE IN THE
PLAYOFFS AND HE STROLLS OFF
AND HE WINS HIS SUPER BOWL
AND IF I'M BREEZE PART OF ME
IS THINKING YOU KNOW WHAT
BRADY WOULDN'T HAVE MADE THE
SUPER BOWL IF HE HAD 19 OF
HIS RIBS BROKEN IN THE MIDDLE
OF NOVEMBER, YOU KNOW AGAIN,
YOU KNOW, LIKE HE'S BROKEN
RIBS AND RIB EXACTLY LIKE
ANATOMY. HE DID MAKE ME HAVE
TO GOOGLE HOW MANY RIBS DOES
A HUMAN BEING HAVE MIKE? LIKE
I ACTUALLY DID LOOK AT THAT,
I WOULDN'T BLAME IF HE
SITTING THERE THINKING LET ME
JUST HEAL UP. I CAN PLAY TILL
SAME, YOU KNOW DB9 SYSTEM.
LIKE I CAN DO THAT TOO. AND
I'VE GOT MICHAEL THOMAS LIKE
I CAN RUN THIS THING BACK. I
WOULDN'T BLAME HIM FOR
THINKING THAT FOR A SPLIT
SECOND AND LOOK AT THE
PRESSURE PUTS ON THE TEAM.
HE'S CUT HIS SALARY BY TWENTY
FOUR POINT NINE TWO FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. HE'S GIVEN
THE TEAM THE ULTIMATE MEAN WE
CAN PRAISE TOM BRADY ALL WE
WANT HE'S NEVER CUT HIS
SALARY TWENTY FOUR POINT NINE
TWO FIVE MILLION IN ONE YEAR
AND HE'S JUST COMING BACK TO
TRY TO HELP THE TEAM WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP AND HEY, I'LL
PLAY HALF THE TIME. HE TOLD
US THAT LAST YEAR WHEN THE
QUESTION WAS.
TAYSOM HILL AND WILLIE BE
BACK. AND WE TALKING ABOUT
HYPOTHETICALS WITH TRULY
SHARING THE JOB AND HE SAID
HE'S GOT NO PROBLEMS LONG AS
THEY WIN. HE'LL PLAY AS MUCH
OR AS LITTLE AS THEY WANT. I
MEAN IF HE WALKS THROUGH THE
DOOR AND SAYS, I'M HERE YOU
WANT TO USE ME USE ME IF
Y'ALL BE A BACKUP BACKUP. I'M
HERE. I'M HERE AND I'M NOT
RETIRING IF YOU WANT TO CUT
ME CUT ME, BUT I'M HERE PUTS
THE SAINTS IN A VERY AWKWARD
SPOT MIKE FLORIO HERE ON THE
RICH EISEN SHOW THE FOOTBALL
YALTA THAT IS KNOWN AS ROONEY
AND ROETHLISBERGER WENT DOWN.
WHAT? WHAT'S THE NUMBER?
WHAT'S NUMBER THAT THESE TWO
GUYS CAN AGREE ON AND GET BEN
BACK OUT THERE? WELL 21
KILLERS HAD AS OF LAST WEEK
NEVER SAID ANYTHING TO
ROETHLISBERGER'S CAMP
SUGGESTING THAT HIS NEW
CONTRACT WOULD BE ANYTHING
OTHER THAN TAKING THE 19
MILLION. HE'S DUE TO MAKE
THIS YEAR TURNING IT INTO A
SIGNING BONUS AS MUCH AS THEY
CAN. YOU STILL HAVE TO HAVE A
1.07 5 MILLION BASE SALARY,
BUT THAT'S 18 .925. IT CAN BE
PAID OUT IN ONE FELL SWOOP
AND YOU EXTEND THE CONTRACT
NUMBER AND YOU GET IN THE
RANGE OF 25 MILLION OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. IT WOULD
TAKE A HALF HOUR TO DO IT. IF
YOU REALLY WANTED TO DO IT
WITH BEEN MAKING 19 MILLION
THE LONGER WE GO WITHOUT THAT
DEAL BEING DONE IN ART
ROONEY HAS SET MARCH 17 IS
THE DEADLINE BECAUSE THAT'S
THE MOMENT THE CAP NUMBER FOR
BEEN BECOMES 40 1.25 MILLION
FOR THE 20 21 LEAGUE YEAR THE
LONGER WE GO THE MORE I
WONDER ARE THE STEELERS GOING
TO SAY TO HIM. HEY BEN. YOU
SAID YOURSELF? I DON'T CARE
HOW MUCH I GET PAID THIS YEAR.
WELL,
THAT BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO .
TAKE YOU UP ON IT. RIGHT AND
THEN THE QUESTION BECOMES HOW
MUCH LESS WILL THEY TRY TO
GET HIM TO TAKE AND AND IF
BREEZE COMES OUT AND SAYS I'M
COMING BACK AND PAYING AT ONE
PLAYING AT ONE POINT. OH
SEVEN FIVE MILLION. HOW DID
THE STEELERS NOT START TO
THINK THAT SOUNDS PRETTY GOOD
TO US TO AND AND THE OTHER
SIDE OF THIS TOO. RICH IF BEN
ROETHLISBERGER WILL CUT TODAY
WITH SOMEONE OFFER HIM 19
MILLION. NO WAY TO PLAY FOR
THEM THIS YEAR. SO, YOU KNOW,
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GO ABOUT
FIGURING OUT WHAT THE NUMBER
IS THAT SOMEONE ELSE WOULD
OFFER HIM. BUT WHATEVER THAT
NUMBER IS, THAT'S THE MOST
THE STEELERS SHOULD WANT TO
PAY HIM.
LAST ONE FOR YOU, MIKE. WHY
DO WE KEEP
HEATING OF THE DAY AND THAT
THEIR YOU KNOW THAT THERE'S A
WANDERLUST POTENTIALLY FOR
COUSINS AND NOW BRIDGEWATER
OR COULD BE A HOME FOR WATSON
WHICH WOULD BLOW ANYTHING
ELSE OUT OF THE WATER WHAT'S
GOING ON? WELL, BRIE THINKS
EVERYTHING'S 123 MISSED GAMES
IN THREE REGULAR SEASONS FOR
JIMMY GAROPPOLO. AND IF I'M
KYLE SHANAHAN, I'M STILL
SALTY ABOUT THE TOUGH-GUY
MANEUVER ON THE SIDELINES
WHERE HE DIPS HIS SHOULDER
AND TEARS HIS ACL AND HE'S
WEEK THREE SECOND THE GAME
AGAINST THE VIKINGS PLAYOFFS.
HE THREW THREE PASSES. ALL OF
THEM SHOULD HAVE BEEN
INTERCEPTED BY ERIC KENDRICKS.
HE INTERCEPTED ONE OF THEM
AFTER THE THIRD ONE THAT
WASN'T PICKED OFF. THAT'S
WHEN THEY WENT INTO BOB
GRIESE MODE FOR THE REST OF
THE POSTSEASON AT LEAST UNTIL
THE SUPER BOWL. HE HAD
EVERYTHING BUT THE BOB GRIESE
GLASSES REMEMBER HOW I USED
TO WEAR THE GLASSES ON ON HIS
FACE WITH HIS HELMET ON IN
THE 70S THROUGH THE THROUGH
WHAT EIGHT PASSES AGAINST THE
PACKERS AND SO THAT'S PART OF
IT AND THEN FINALLY 25
MILLION JUST LIKE BIG BEN
WHO'S GOING TO PAY OF
GAROPPOLO'S AVAILABLE RIGHT
NOW.
I'M 25 MILLION THIS YEAR NO
BUDDY. SO IF THEY COULD GET
COUSINS, I THINK THEY JUMP ON
IT VIKINGS AREN'T LETTING
THEM GO VIKINGS NEED TO KEEP
COUSINS AROUND IN ORDER TO
HELP PEOPLE. REMAIN EMPLOYED
BEYOND 2020 ONE IN MINNESOTA.
THEY GET TO THE PLAYOFFS LIKE
THEY DO EVERY OTHER YEAR. SO
I DON'T THINK HE'S GOING TO
BE IN THE MIX BUT I THINK THE
49ERS GOING TO LOOK FOR AN
UPGRADE SOMEBODY DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR CHEAPER AND I STILL
BELIEVE THE GAROPPOLO IS
GOING TO BE CUT BECAUSE
NOBODY'S GONNA TRADE FOR THAT
CONTRACT AND WHY WOULD HE
REDUCED HIS CONTRACT TO
FACILITATE A TRADE JUST SAY
CUT ME AND I'LL GO PICK MY
TEAM WITH THE PATRIOTS BE
THAT TEAM THE PATRIOTS JUMP
ALL OVER HIM ARE THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY BE THAT TEAM BUT
I'D HAVE THE SAME CONCERN
THAT THE 49ERS HAVE LOOK THE
GUY HAD A FOUR-GAME AUDITION
IN 2016 WHEN TOM BRADY WAS
SUSPENDED. HE GOT HURT IN THE
SECOND GAME. THAT'S MY
CONCERN. AND WITH THE RULES
SKEWED IN FAVOR OF THE
QUARTERBACK FOR THE MOST
PROTECTED PLAYERS ON THE
FIELD OTHER THAN THE PUNTER
IN THE KICKER. HOW DO YOU GET
INJURED AS OFTEN AS JIMMY
GAROPPOLO DOES AND AT A
CERTAIN POINT IT'S NOT JUST
BAD LUCK. IT'S SOMETHING
ABOUT YOU AND I WANT A
QUARTERBACK WHO'S GOING TO
SHOW UP AND PLAY EVERY SINGLE
WEEK. YOU NEED THAT
IF YOU WANT TO BE A
CONTESTANT.  STARTING AND
ENDING ON THE NBC SPORTS ON
PEACOCK DAY EVERY DAY AND
LOOK FOR MY CALL. LET'S DO
THIS FAR MORE OFTEN ANYTIME
RICH RIGHT BACK AT YA, THAT'S
IT. THAT'S MIKE FLORIO. I PRO
FOOTBALL TALK MUST FOLLOW. IS